[Music]
a new variant of the coronavirus has
been found in nevada health officials
say
it is more contagious the new strain
first emerged in the uk
last fall and it's been popping up in
the u.s in recent weeks
orco mana joining us live with more on
what experts say
we should do about this orco
well brian the uk strain of covet 19 has
been found
in at least 24 states in the u.s and
that now
includes nevada because of that some
local experts say we should step
up our prevention efforts public health
measures
are increasingly more important keeping
our community safe as a covet-19 variant
is found in nevada
this week officials announced the uk
strain of the virus was detected
in a specimen from a las vegas woman
it's able to
potentially infect more people dr mark j
khan with the unlv school of medicine
tells me it's still unclear whether the
uk strain is more deadly
more research needs to be done but
experts agree it's around 50 percent
more contagious so mitigation measures
for high risk groups should be increased
that includes double masking the greater
the barrier you have between yourself
and others the less likely you're able
that this virus is able to be
transmitted
dr khan adds it's also important to keep
your time inside places like grocery
stores limited
with a more contagious variant we need
to be even more careful
while research shows the coven 19
vaccine is effective against new virus
strains pfizer and moderna are working
on booster shots to better fight them
in other words modulating the mrna
vaccine
to take that variant into account and
then potentially being prepared
to give people a booster shot if that
becomes necessary
two doses is still the current
recommendation dr khan says the vaccine
is our best protection as soon as your
time comes up to get vaccinated you got
to get vaccinated
now i ask the southern nevada health
district if it is officially
recommending any extra steps
in the statement it says in part quote
the same measures we have been advising
to everyone to take
are effective against the variant strain
found in one clark county resident
those measures include wearing a mask
avoiding large gatherings
social distancing and disinfecting
surfaces reporting live in las vegas
tonight orca mana 8 news now